gaze against groomers recently did a
sting operation where they had somebody
pretending to be a 14 year old girl
claiming to be trans call Planned
Parenthood who then referred her to a
community Health Care Network for help
and they proceeded to tell her that they
would give her information on obtaining
certain treatments despite her being
underage she said I don't want my
parents to find out about this we will
will play some uh do you guys remember
being 14. yeah vaguely yeah I didn't
want your parents to find out about
anything that you thought about anything
please knock yes you better knock or you
might see me oh boy and they started
talking we have um we have this this
moment here uh from uh again the the
footage that gays against groomers has
posted to Twitter where
the uh person impersonating a 14 year
old tells the uh people at the the
organization that Planned Parenthood
referred her to that she is a minor that
she doesn't want her parents to find out
and this is what they say okay just give
me one moment finding anything hold on
and you're sure my mom won't find out
yeah now cold Cindy is when um we have
to put labels on your chart so as soon
as I make this chart it's going to be
contact by phone only and then it's just
gonna be the number you give me I'm
gonna put no mail for your address and
then that's it if anyone ever calls for
you
um we can't disclose any information if
it's not you
know I mean because I'm under age
you understood but we help underage
patients receive care that they need and
one as long as you know it's not harmful
to oneself we try to help you out the
best we can
okay I'm so nervous my Palms are
sweating
I'm watching um right now but the only
thing is right now I'm already at the
end of August looking and I'm not
getting any appointments all right so
you guys get the picture here basically
this person's underage they're saying
they don't want their parents to know
about the treatment that they're seeking
out and this person is saying don't
worry we won't tell them it's a code
Cindy now I want to point something out
because I'm sure a lot of apologists for
Planned Parenthood are going to make the
claim
that this wasn't Planned Parenthood
saying that she should do this they were
just referring her which is kind of an
interesting point because Planned
Parenthood has claimed for decades that
they perform mammograms and give women
mammograms when they actually don't have
a single mammogram uh on site at any of
their clinics they just refer women do
clinics where they can get them but of
course we know they're going to embrace
that double standard and say no we
weren't actually providing any of this
care we were just telling this person
where we could get or where they could
get it that said maybe they bite the
bullet and they say this is affirming
care they absolutely needed it it's
abusive and horrible not to give it to
them I also wonder if this organization
that she was referred to is going to say
oh well when we said we want to give her
medical care uh we're just talking about
like medical care that's necessary for
her life which is a Dodge that they
usually use in order to not acknowledge
that they're giving these children
hormones that stunt their development to
groom them on a path towards mutilation
yeah I mean the
parent at the beginning of recording
refers this person who's obviously an
adult posing as 14 year old to the
Community Health Care Network the
community healthcare Network when this
person asks like I need help he's like
what what do you want specifically like
I just want help I I I want uh you know
you help and he's the operator
specifically brings up hormone therapy
uh so they are all aware of what a minor
who identifies as transgender may
possibly be seeking out or they're aware
of what specifically to offer they do
mention mental health care as one of the
services they provide they also mention
uh medical intervention in the form of
hormones and I find it interesting that
uh we would have anyone trying to deny
this right like why when you have this
kind of recording wouldn't you just
double down on like well we're supposed
to be doing this like this is where this
kind of logic falls apart that's what
happens right first they say we're not
doing it then they say we are doing it
and it's good a similar thing happened
when Libs of tick tock called I forget
which what the name of the hospital was
but it was a children's hospital this
was last summer it was in Washington D.C
Boston was the first thing and that
whole thing was very interesting because
we did some post-millennial did some
reporting about what was going on at
Boston Children's Hospital we had the
intake form so we had the forms that
said
um uh vaginoplasty would be performed on
young men at the age of 17. we had these
on the actual documentation from Boston
Children's Hospital uh the one for young
women to have
um phalloplasties right was at 18.
however you could get it at 18 which
means that there was prep prior to that
probably exactly before you could
consent you could right and so what was
interesting about that was lips of tick
tock posted that Boston Children's
Hospital was doing hysterectomies on
minors and that's what everyone got
slammed for was that she was saying that
we don't have evidence that they weren't
necessarily doing that we only have
their word but they also scrubbed their
site anyway
so after that Libs of tick tock Haya she
called the Washington children's
hospital she posed
very very obviously and transparently
actually if I remember correctly
um as a mom seeking to get you know sex
change for her underage child and she
had a similar experience she ended up
reaching essentially the phone answering
person who said yes we do that right who
said like yes we can take care of that
we could do I believe it was a double
mastectomy kind of stuff like that
um and now we have another situation
like that uh
and again
this will come out where they're going
to say that this is a good thing to do
because I don't think so because gender
drugs are life-saving and it's a
manipulation of language we had a mom
actually pose this was last like a year
or so ago uh calling the getting
involved the treasure Trevor Project
posing as a 15 year old with gender
dysphoria and the same thing happened
the mom was as being posing as this 15
year old girl the mom was referred to
all of these services to get more gender
medical yeah services and when she tried
to at another instance when she tried to
get information on detransitioning the
Trevor Project was decidedly unhelpful
and said things like are you sure that
you want to de-transition this sounds
like internalized transphobia yep that's
exactly right so a person can't be like
groomed into becoming trans there's no
social contagion there even though even
wpath admits there is but when somebody
de-transitions that's because the people
around them have manipulated them
psychologically not wanting to be trans
basically I think it's interesting with
this call too one of the first things I
noticed that it to me it did not sound
like a 14 year old like there's a sort
of like a South Park character right
have you ever heard a 14 year old talk
about how their palms are sweating or
she was like I'm underage like you don't
say that when you're no well my limit
was like can you spell your email and
this person goes like Amazon married
like if you're 14 you're not doing that
because you've never had to deal with
that many calls you just keep saying m
waiting for somebody to understand what
you're saying I think what I noticed
about that call is that the guy on the
other end of the line was like as long
as it's not harmful to the person and
there's this I guess the Divergence of
the entire Global conversation on this
is is are the chemicals harmful for 14
year olds or younger or whatever or are
they not and I think that's part of the
problem is that the information is not
clearly presented like the risks are not
included and this is true for a lot of
prescription medication in the U.S but I
had someone in my personal life recently
tell me oh well Top surgery and
mastectomies are not the same thing and
I have to be like what are you talking
about that's exactly the same what do
you what do you think they're doing and
they're like no no no mastectomy is
different and I was like what do you
think is happening in Top surgery like
there is this what did they say they
couldn't explain it they said you leave
part of the breast no you don't I don't
I mean there's no sometimes it gets
botched and you have weird flaps and
things like I've seen this yeah um
there's different kinds of ways to
perform this surgery there's that gender
surgeon in Miami who does it and eating
the
video about how she was only yeading
four teats during so she was sad about
it one week poses with these minors but
um that doctor has had a number of
complications from patients because of
the type the way that she does it where
there's um what is it no drainage and so
people end up young women have ended up
with uh Rotting Flesh on their bodies
and had to go to hospitals yeah and
hospitals are like uh you're gonna die
you have your flesh is rotting yeah I
think that's the problem like I
understand that there is an argument for
you have to be conscious someone's
emotional state and we're trying to be
compassionate and open-minded and
whatever else I understand that that's
where uh certain positions on this on
these issues come from but I think
ultimately if you just go back and say
like well what are the consequences of
taking high doses of estrogen of
testosterone of removing tissue that's
naturally occurring your body of uh just
disrupting the parts of your body that
regulate your hormones like there is no
way that there are not costs and
consequences and I think we can all
agree in this room that under the age of
18 you are not in a position to make a
fully informed decision and I think part
of the problem is that over 18 the
information is still not presented
exactly ethically and clearly well
exactly and that's a very important
Point there's a lot we can say about
these surgical interventions there's a
lot we can say about these hormones but
I really want to flag what you're saying
about someone choosing to do this after
they're over the age of 18 when they
have been told throughout their entire
adolescence that this is something they
should be doing we recognize that
groomers don't always get physical when
the person is underage sometimes what
happens is a groomer meets somebody who
is underage and then they groom them
into placing themselves in that role so
that when they're 18 they can get
together with them if you have a 40 year
old man who knew a girl when she was 14
and 15 and was talking to her and then
as soon as she turned 18 they started
dating we would recognize that that was
grooming even though she was technically
legally age because we know that if a
groomer gets to someone when they're
young and more vulnerable they can try
to brainwash them and so it's a similar
phenomena if you put a child on these
hormones then even if you're waiting
until they're 18 to actually perform the
surgical interventions you've already
warped their mind in the direction of
embracing that intervention to the point
where you couldn't say they've actually
consented even if you did consent to
something like that it would be wrong
because healthy body parts are not meant
to be removed emulated but even so you
can't make the argument that it's not
grooming just because they waited until
the person was over the age of 18 to
intervene surgically because groomers
wait until the person they're praying
upon is over I disagree with you when it
comes really relationships and things
like that I mean if if if if a if a man
is 40 and he has a relationship with an
18 year old girl but if he knew her when
he was 15 and he's planting seeds like
when she was 15 I'm saying yeah we
recognize universally that that's
grooming yeah I mean I think that we see
stuff like that throughout history
um you know but I don't I don't think
that you can make those kind of
you kind of have to meet people where
they stand right I mean relationships
are weird thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time